Les médecins...
Ces héros...
Ces demi-dieux qui ont le pouvoir de guérir
et même le pouvoir de vie et de mort sur leurs congénères....
Mais si un grand pouvoir implique de grandes responsabilités,
il peut aussi faire perdre le sens des réalités.
Voici 5 types de médecins à qui vous n'avez pas du tout envie
de confier votre petit corps gracieux !
Et vous avez bien raison !
1ère catégorie : le médecin trop conciliant !
Et oui ça peut paraître bizarre mais des fois c'est bien
quand un médecin refuse de faire ce que vous lui demandez.
Quand vous demandez quelque chose de pas raisonnable par exemple.
Tenez, prenez le Dr Conrad Murray.
L'homme qui a tué Michael Jackson.
Bah si il avait su dire non à son client quand
en plus du cocktail de médicaments qu'il prenait déjà,
il lui a demandé un anesthésiant en guise de somnifère.
Bah Michael serait encore en vie !
Enfin il serait pas mort si tôt en tout cas...
Enfin il serait pas mort de ça...
'Fin bon... Bref !
Imaginez, c'est un peu comme si vous demandiez à votre médecin
de vous prescrire une chimio pour plus avoir besoin de vous épiler.
Ça peut marcher mais c'est pas bon pour vous !
Pour sa défense Conrad Murray a dit, je cite :
Une façon un peu malaisante de dire qu'il mettait une sonde urinaire
tous les soirs au chanteur parce qu'il faisait pipi au lit.
Normalement dans ces cas-là une couche, ça suffit.
Quand je vous dis qu'il est vraiment trop conciliant...
Autre type de médecin à fuir comme la peste.
Après celui qui est trop conciliant, celui qui se croit tout puissant,
qui oublie que vous êtes là et que vous avez votre mot à dire.
Comme Graeme Stephen Reeves.
En 2002 ce médecin australien opérait une de ses patientes
d'une tumeur au niveau de la vulve.
Des lèvres pour être précis.
Et au lieu d'enlever uniquement la tumeur...
Bah il a tout retiré, y compris le clitoris.
Une infirmière qui a témoigné à son procès a raconté que
quand elle lui a fait remarquer que la patiente était pas au courant
qu'il allait tout retirer et qu'elle n'avait pas donner son consentement.
Il a dit que de toute façon, étant donné qu'elle était veuve,
elle aurait plus besoin de tout ça.
Ensuite il a retiré ses gants de chirurgien.
Il est monté sur son cheval et il est rentré chez lui...
Au Moyen-Âge...
"Silence manante, ou tu vas prendre une claquade !"
Non en vrai, Graeme Reeves, il a fini en prison
parce qu'il s'est avéré que des centaines de plaintes
ont été déposées contre lui pour mutilation et agression sexuelle.
Le boucher de Bega comme on l'a appelé,
il a bien été radié de l'Ordre des Médecins.
Mais par contre il est sorti de prison au bout de 18 mois.
Toujours à la catégorie des bouchers,
deux médecins qui ont exercé en France.
Un dentiste et un chirurgien esthétique.
Le premier s'appelle Mark Van Nierop.
Mais vous le connaissez peut-être sous le nom du Dentiste de l'horreur.
Il a été jugé en février 2016 pour avoir mutilé des dizaines de patients.
Dents saines dévitalisées.
Arrachage par paquets de huit.
Gencives coupées, douleurs, j'en passe et des meilleurs !
Le tout pour l'appât de l'argent
et sans jamais montrer la moindre compassion.
Pas même à son procès.
Le second c'est le Dr Maure.
Alors je sais pas vous, mais moi un médecin avec un nom pareil...
D'emblée je suis pas serein...
Il s'avère que le bonhomme pratiquait la chirurgie esthétique
comme d'autres le fist-fucking....
À la hussarde et sans anesthésie.
Sauf que là en l’occurrence les patients n'étaient pas du tout consentants.
Certains ont raconté que pendant les interventions,
ils sentaient les mains du chirurgien sous leur peau...
Pour un résultat en plus, assez approximatif.
#Euphémisme
Avant la fin de son procès, le Dr Maure s'est enfui
sur son yacht hein... Normal !
Mais bon il a fini par être rattrapé
et il a été condamné à 4 ans de prison dont 1 avec sursis.
Autre catégorie de médecins à éviter à tout prix.
L'apprenti sorcier !
Celui qui tente des trucs qui sont pas dans le manuel.
Comme Oneal Ron Morris,
une jeune chirurgienne esthétique amateur
qui officiait en Floride sans diplôme
et avec des méthodes très personnelles...
Pour ses opérations de remodelage des joues,
des lèvres et des fesses et du menton,
elle injectait à ses patientes un mélange de colle,
de mousse anti-crevaison, d'huile et de ciment.
Le tout dans des chambres d'hôtel ou directement au domicile de ses patientes.
Après plusieurs cas d'infections graves
et même après un décès,
elle a eu l'occasion d'aller méditer au calme en prison,
sur la notion d'exercice illégal de la médecine.
Et d'hygiène aussi...
Comme la majorité de ses congénères,
Oneal Ron Morris a gagné dans l'histoire un joli petit surnom :
"Dr Fesse Toxique"
Non vraiment...
Être créatif, pour un décorateur d'intérieur c'est cool...
Pour un coiffeur à la limite...
Mais pour un chirurgien, tapez plutôt dans le conventionnel.
Dernière catégorie, celle des médecins qui se donne
un peu trop corps et âme à leur métier.
Premier exemple : Cecil Jacobson.
Un médecin du Colorado spécialisé dans les inséminations artificielles...
Vous le sentez venir...
Et oui le bonhomme avait la sinistre habitude de
remplir lui-même les stocks de sa banque de sperme.
Il fécondait ses patientes avec ses propres échantillons.
Et il allait parfois jusqu'à remplacer ceux de leur mari.
Il aurait ainsi donné naissance à 70
voir 80 enfants ce qui lui a valu :
1 : le surnom d'Inséminator.
2 : d'inspirer un film.
Et 3 : un petit séjour en prison...
Autre spécimen : le britannique Bertold Wiesner
que j'ai personnellement surnommé InséminHardcore !
Il a exercé jusqu'au milieu des années 60,
dans les mêmes conditions que son confrère Cecil Jacobson.
Il pourrait être le géniteur de 300 à 600 enfants
voire un millier selon certaines estimations.
Il a fallu faire des estimations parce que le poteau rose
a été découvert qu'après sa mort.
Voilà la prochaine fois que vous irez chez votre médecin...
Bah faites lui un petit bisou !
Ok... Il est relou parce qu'il est toujours en retard
et qu'il écrit comme un salaud.
Mais vous auriez pu plus mal tomber non ?
Ce Top est terminé, si vous avez des questions à me poser
sur la santé ou le corps humain, laissez-moi ça dans les commentaires.
On se retrouve très vite pour parler de choses
qui nous concernent toutes et tous.
Où ça ? Dans Ton Corps.
Abonne-toi !